good evening and thank you for coming to
this evening's fusco foundation lecture
we're delighted that you've joined us
who says that you can't have a great
gathering in the month of August in
Washington DC we are incredibly honored
this evening that Stan Evans has joined
us Stan has had a remarkable lasting
enduring impact on not only Hillsdale
College but the whole of the
conservative world of ideas and action
and we're so grateful for all the T has
done we're looking forward to the
remarks that he's offered this evening I
had the pleasure of meeting Stan while I
was an undergraduate student at
Hillsdale College and he endured my
stumbling stuttering questions as I
interviewed him his book the theme is
freedom had just come out religion
politics in the American tradition it's
as good now as it was then he's penned
some eight others the amount of not only
information about sort of what what has
transpired in our world but wisdom that
Stan brings is really wonderful you're
all in for a treat tonight but before I
turn things over to our student
introducer I wanted to take just a quick
trip back through history and that is in
Primus now has been around for a little
bit more than 40 years I would venture
to guess that most of you in this room
have now receive it does anybody go back
to getting the the first issue by chance
anybody here maybe somewhere in the
seventh year eighth year of its
existence or something
well the very first Center for
constructive alternatives which is the
lecture series four of them are held on
Hill sales campus every year sparked the
first in Primus and among the the the
very view that followed then I don't
think it was quite the first but it was
right there as part of the first CCA was
a talk that Stan gave called there is no
urban crisis he had an another talk that
appeared in in Primus this one from June
of 1975 government can be hazardous to
your health an evergreen topic if there
ever was one
this one August of 1976 the liberal
Twilight were that it were so March 1980
unlearning the liberal history lessons
and thoughts concerning conservatism and
freedom this is a reflection on in part
mr. Evans's studies with ludwig von
mises the other in Primus there are a
couple of copies by the way of each of
these out on the table don't all run to
get them because there aren't many but
on your way out if you if you'd like a
copy the religious roots of freedom
which marked the publication of Stan's
book that I that I just mentioned we're
really thrilled that for many decades
now
Hillsdale students have had occasion to
intern at the national journalism Center
which standed one of those students
could not be here this evening but
offered a reflection and I wanted to
share just a little bit of it to give
you a flavor of what it is to have been
a student and mentee of Stan Evans this
comes from Paula roe than Paula Rowe
Miller who's the Hillsdale class of 1985
she interned at the National journalism
Center in 1983 she says this I was an
NGC intern
he was so very kind to me such a great
mentor leader and role model later after
I graduated from Hillsdale Evans and
Novak offered me a job based on my
internship at MJC and my connection with
Stan mr. Novak and I attended Stan's
50th birthday party together and it was
a great time I'm still in the Washington
DC area and I credit Stan and his
confidence in me and I all will always
be grateful to him for his advice
mentoring Direction guidance and
kindness I think there are many of us
who will echo those sentiments for those
of you have not had occasion to to meet
M Stanton Evans you're in for a treat
this evening to give a more complete
introduction than per Hillsdale College
tradition is Lauren MacDonald a rising
senior at the college Lauren is studying
politics and economics she's been active
in a number of different groups and this
summer she's been interning in the
development department of the Leadership
Institute Lauren
M Stanton Evans has been a journalist
and leader in the conservative movement
for over four decades a native of Texas
and author of nine books he has written
for National Review the Los Angeles
Times syndicate and the Freeman and
served for 14 years as editor of the
Indianapolis News mr. Evans was a
political commentator for news
organizations such as CBS in National
Public Radio for over 20 years and he
founded the national journalism Center
in 1977
a former chairman of the American
Conservative Union he is currently a
professor at Troy University thank you
thank you very much
Oh mine great to be here and thank you
for the kind introduction and the kind
remarks by David I really appreciate all
of them and nice to see a lot of old
friends here that I have not seen for a
while and some new ones and I'm glad to
be with all of you folks there will be
time I'm gonna try to just watch it
actually works it doesn't look like it
but by the way I paid $10 for this four
years ago at Walmart and it's already
falling apart like whatever happens our
quality anyway I'm gonna keep an eye on
the time there'll be time for questions
there will be microphones handed around
and I'm glad of that because I'm a
little bit deaf in one ear and some of
you've heard me say this before but when
you get old a couple of bad things
happen to you wanted your hearing starts
to go and I forget what the other one is
I probably think of it in a minute
I am honored always to be invited to any
Hillsdale event I'm a great fan of
Hillsdale many friends there as
professors former students alumni people
who've come through the program there
and gone on to do things in the world
beyond I'm sort of an amateur student of
history I'm not a historian I am a
journalist by profession as it's clear
from my introduction and that makes me a
little bit of an outsider and in the
realm of history I'm not only a
journalist I'm a conservative journalist
which is an oxymoron like jumbo shrimp
or
rap music my current favorite Senate
Ethics Committee anyway i i've been
delving into some of these things for
years and and as David indicated
associate with Hillsdale for many years
and the time frame there is a long when
it's best measured by carbon dating but
for the young folks were like really
like prehistoric stuff and but it's
great to be with you and I am honored
David asked me to talk about Watergate
and Obama Kate or whatever going to call
what's going on now for some of the
young folks here I'm sure Watergate it
doesn't mean very much it's an episode
from the Nixon era back in the 70s and
that's for the undergraduates now is
like the war of 1812 or something it's
been a long time ago something that I've
said before for the some who are closer
to my demographic here is that I was
never for Nixon until Watergate
I I was not too thrilled with a lot of
other stuff that Nixon was doing like
going to Communist China with dr.
Kissinger and they talked with Brezhnev
and solve agreements and ABM treaties
and wage and price controls and founding
EPA and OSHA and we're all Kansans now
and so forth after all of that to me
Watergate was like a breath of fresh air
we meet at a strangely appropriate time
for this discussion today is the
anniversary of Nixon's resignation in
1974 I think I'm right August 8 1974 we
also meet during a time of crisis for
the Washington Post
because I'm very broken up about that
I'm sure you are to that oh it's just
been losing money and you know result
err Jeff Bezos
the Amazon guy but the Washington Post
made its reputation on destroying Nixon
that's what for the young folks here
that's that's what made them great
that was a journalistic coup of a great
moment and I used to talk to the interns
at njc about this and what the post did
was to get somebody to hand them a bunch
of stuff if you've ever seen the movie
all the President's Men we've seen this
yeah yeah it'll probably run forever
unfortunately but I told my students hey
it's not like that so in that world the
way it works was somebody called you up
on the phone and said meet me in a
parking garage off K Street or something
in the middle of the night and I'll give
you a bunch of secrets so you go there
and you get to Secrets you go back and
write your story they print destroyed
you destroy the president and you look
like Robert Redford that has not been my
experience in any in any aspects of that
whatsoever anyway that's the benchmark
for scandals a president forced to
resign because of cover-ups and abuse of
power and so forth and it's very
interesting benchmarks to use now what's
going on today and Obama gate or what
are we going to call it we have at least
three scandals percolating today there's
the IRS scandal and the Benghazi scandal
and the NSA scandal and they're all kind
of out there the three-ring circus and
there are others beyond those but those
are kind of the main one
and those are indeed reminiscent of
things that were talked about during the
Watergate era back there 40 years ago
the comparisons are several the issues
are the same
the IRS part is identical in many ways
are structurally identical but thinking
about this and I don't always or
frequently talk about this subject the
social background extends beyond
Watergate unless we understand that
background we don't understand Watergate
itself and therefore we do not have the
perspective we need on today's events
the abuse of power by the executive
branch of government far predated
Watergate it goes back to Franklin D
Roosevelt who used the power of the
government to attack and destroy his
enemies in the late 1930s and of course
during the war he was opposed by a group
call America first headed by Charles
Lindbergh general Robert would people
who are against our involvement in that
war and I'm not going to go on the
merits of that but they were opponents
of Roosevelt the circle isolationist and
the government mobilized its power to
destroy those people and a magazine that
represented their point of view called
scriveners commentator and they put that
magazine out of business that was back
under FDR and who also inaugurated why
aren't you having much wiretapping back
then this continued under true and very
Truman cover-ups occurred as well two of
them that I've written about in books
involved the manipulation of grand
juries obstruction of justice first in
the am eraser case and then in the grand
jury that met in 1947 to hear the case
of about 40 Soviet agents who had been
on the federal payroll
that grand jury was made also to get
those people free and they did walk free
at that time but the real culmination of
this that is most relevant to Watergate
and events today was under John F
Kennedy and subtly under Lyndon Johnson
nothing was done whatsoever under Nixon
that had not been done by Kennedy and
you're not gonna hear this in many
venues and they're gonna read it many
history books but it's true if sensitive
wiretapping was done under Kennedy there
was a campaign waged to silence his
opponents by using the Internal Revenue
Service the so-called Fairness Doctrine
was founded at a really modern forum
under Kennedy and the list is long
measures that were taken to silence
opponents of the new frontier I wasn't
working journalist at the time this was
going on and some of this for you then
the key to it was a document called the
ruther memorandum and anybody wants to
can get this document online was written
by man named Victor Luthor who was the
brother of Walter Reuther who was a
leading official of the United Auto
Workers Union they were big backers of
Kennedy and the new frontier and opposed
to conservatives in all their
modulations the ruther memorandum
spelled out a game plan for silencing
conservatives in a book I wrote in 1965
called the liberal establishment I had a
chapter devoted to this called the
silencers in which the IRS refused the
FCC was used any other mechanism could
be used was used to crush conservative
dissent and it had a fair amount of
effect
and this is not just my say-so there's a
book I would recommend also by a man
named Fred friendly who was impeccably
liberal I don't have enemy have any of
you might have seen the movie good night
and good luck which was an attack from
Senator Joe McCarthy by George Clooney
Clooney in that movie played the part of
Fred friendly that was the character he
portrayed who was a producer for Edward
or Merle Fred friendly wrote a book
about this effort to suppress
conservative dissent called the good
guys the bad guys and the First
Amendment he explained in some detail
how this effort to crush conservative
dissent went forward particularly with
respect to broadcasting the Fairness
Doctrine and so on so if you look at
that record if you look at what happened
back to them and compare it to what is
going on now it's amazing by the way
this is the ruther memorandum for those
who are interested in which I had pulled
down off the web and it's fairly well
known for people who study this kind of
stuff let me just read you part of it
this is sort of a to-do list for the
Kennedy administration and they did it
they did what it says this point number
three the flow of big money to the
radical right should be damned
to the extent possible that's the
heading under that heading there's a
discussion of things that can be done to
silence conservatives one of them is to
audit them through the Internal Revenue
Service to deny them tax-exempt status
to use the power of the IRS to silence
them it was done all of this was done
and then some under John F Kennedy and
Bobby Kennedy
in the early sixties and we knew about
it back then everything there was later
laid to the doorstep of Richard Nixon
was done by the Kennedys in the early
sixties continued by Lyndon Johnson when
he ascended to the White House including
the involvement of the president
personally John Kennedy personally
there's a man in fact this is the
linkage to the Washington Post men have
Ben Bradlee he's still around
so extent and he was a big deal back in
the day when Kennedy was president Ben
Bradlee was then the executive editor of
Newsweek which is owned by the
Washington Post he then transitioned
through the puffs it was a big player
and the Watergate scandal for those
who'd seen the movie he's Jason Robards
that's that's Ben Bradley Ben Bradley
wrote a book came out in 1974 the same
year of Nixon step down called
conversations with Kennedy and I
recommend this to you if you have not
seen it it's a fairly short book he
talks about all kinds of stuff that was
going on under Kennedy he was a big
buddy of Kennedy's and spent a lot of
time with him socially and he recounts
an episode in which Kennedy starts
talking to him to Ben Bradley it's not
Jason Robards now this is actually
picking Presley talking to Kennedy and
Kennedy goes into the tax returns of
certain wealthy Americans and tells
Robards Bradley that certain people very
wealthy people are not paying very much
Texas and at one point one of us john
paul Getty and who I think according to
Kennedy and the preceding year it paid
five hundred dollars in taxes and I
thought I need to talk to his accountant
two would be a good accountant to him
and then Kennedy says according to
Bradley I guess I shouldn't be telling
me this it's probably illegal yes it
probably was then Bradley never wrote a
word about this at the time but it's in
his book this kind of stuff went on a
lot back in the day in response to the
ruther memorandum and the general push
by Bobby who was in attorney general
physician achieved entirely on merit
the IRS launched a project for the
ideological organizations project this
is identical to what has been going on
under the IRS today step-by-step Diana
you said you have this book right look
called power to destroy this is by the
way another book by the liberal not by
the conservative the very first two
chapters in this book power to destroy
by man named John a Andrew third is
about this ideological organizations
project and the lists of organizations
who are targeted by the IRS to shut them
down and surprise they were conservative
organizations all that's in response to
what the ruther memorandum said and in
response to what Kennedy was saying in
his speeches his evil radical right
extremists must be countered the
ideological origins project continued
for many years I think we've got finally
shut down under Johnson but I'm not sure
about that one of the things that they
did back then it's uncanny how similar
these events words or what is happening
in them was they clearly had and this
book spells this out in great detail
they had a list of maybe a couple dozen
it was expanded conservative groups and
all of these were targeted for audits
have their tax exemptions taken away
just in general hassled by the IRS
because of their conservatism it's very
clear they realized that if the news got
out that they were doing this it would
look like they were persecuting people
for their political beliefs imagine that
and therefore they said what we should
do is leaven this with a few left-wing
organizations and they did and I think
in my account was they had twenty
different groups that they were looking
at 19 of them were conservative one of
them was left-wing they did nothing to
that one I'm doing this from memory now
sir I need to be double checked on this
that one was the fair play for Cuba
committee which was the organizations
which Lee Harvey Oswald belonged the
Harvey Oswald was a member of the fair
play for Cuba committee but they didn't
do anything the fair play for Cuba
committee it was just there to for
cosmetic purposes really what's
happening now it's exactly the same
except more so I don't have the exact
figures but there's some this is I I was
never do this I'm gonna cite to you a
report by National Public Radio now I
used to kind of work there as a of a fig
leaf conservative commentator but this
is this report that they're basing is on
Dave camp who's the chairman of the
House Ways and Means Committee but they
reported and they have a mix they have
the total number of conservative
organizations according to this that has
been looked at by the IRS was 104 104
conservative groups the number of the
circle progressive groups was seven
so well you can do that math probably
better than I can
147 the questions asked of the
conservative groups and they were I
think we all know about this work is
under Obama now what books do you read
what is one group that's about its
players what what do you send your
prayers like deliver us from Obama I
mean and many many questions of that
yield the tote the subtotal this is the
through July 20 not pretty recent 1552
questions asked of the conservative
groups 33 questions asked of the
progressive groups whatever they were
opting conservative groups 46 percent
were finally approved after a long delay
and this delay by the way lasted through
the 2012 election that was the point of
it there's voter suppression activity
the progressive groups were denied 0
times what's going on here I don't get
this and it's very confusing if they're
being impartial why would that be I
don't know how to explain that and there
are many other many many other examples
of this the point is that's exactly what
happened back in the day under Kennedy
it's happening now 50 years later the
same thing it's like there's just you
know off-the-shelf stuff go to the shelf
and get the same thing and we'll do it
again there's virtually nothing they're
doing now that was not done under
Kennedy and it wasn't just Kennedy I
mean it was over Johnson also but far
surpass what was done by Nixon as far as
I can tell
Nixon did have a several enemies list
and I know something about this because
I was told I didn't know this myself I
told this
by ABC TV I was on it and the reason I
was on it according to them was at that
time I was chairman of the American
Conservative Union and we were very
critical of Nixon and we backed our
former chairman a man named John
ashbrook in the primaries against Nixon
in 1972 and that apparently got me on
this list which is the only thing abc-tv
well they once interviewed me about
quail but they had to interview me about
being on the enemies list for Nixon they
didn't want to interview her about
anything else but that was that was of
interest to them well Nixon did have an
enemies list he did try to mobilize the
IRS to some degree against groups that
were unfavorable to him and that spelled
out in a number of these studies too
including this book but he didn't get
very far because the professional
staffers and IRS were not interested in
helping Nixon but they were quite
interested in helping Kennedy and that's
the difference from another I have
another Nixon and Kennedy it's a
different what happened in there Nixon
what's happening now the IRS is not a
reluctant dragon when it comes to going
after conservative groups quite the
contrary
and we see now the numbers
investigations there and just to
finalize on that according to this
information I have this was a Paul
Bedard column a couple of days ago an
examiner there were 292 conservative
groups audited or being targeted in some
fashion versus I believe six so you can
see there is an imbalance there maybe
that's you know apparent on the numbers
that again is the same thing that
happened under candidate something else
that happened under
in some ways even worse was a series of
cover-ups
a very dramatic and disturbing nature
one that is relevant to some other
historical matters was the overthrow of
President diem in South Vietnam and of
on November 1st 1963 just three weeks
before Kennedy himself was murdered
that overthrow of diem was organized by
our government and the main action in
that case was on behalf of the State
Department by a guy named Roger Hillsman
by Henry Cabot Lodge who had been
Nixon's running mate and 60 who was then
our ambassador to Saigon they overthrew
him or encouraged they could I talk
against him which led to his murder and
led to the disintegration of the
anti-communist resistance in Vietnam
it's all downhill from their own that
happened under John F Kennedy whether
Kent I don't think Kennedy himself knew
about it but certainly he went back to
his people and finally okay there's so
many of these cases he's going forever
I've written about these in books and
the past and really pointing things up
from memory now the man named otto
attempt cook who was a staffer in the
government in charge of security matters
for the State Department and he was on
the trail of a number of security risks
in the government under several
administrations but this culminated
under Kennedy and one of the people who
was in his sights as a man named John
Stewart service who was a foreign
service diplomat involved in the circle
Amerasian case which was fixed by the
Justice Department under Troon and he
stayed on service until
the Kennedy years and hotep kill was on
his trail and on the trail of other
people he believed were security risks
or questionable in the State Department
at that time and TEPCO therefore ran
afoul of the Kennedy administration who
did not want this to happen the
administration therefore wiretapped him
ransacked his office bugged his
telephone and persecuted him in every
conceivable way this all happened in the
early sixties again far in excess of
anything ever done under Richard Nixon
and one can go on I will not I think
that's enough of this stuff but what I
think it shows to me and I hope will
maybe encourage some people to look
further into this is that much of our
real history not just so the Cold War
but of our domestic politics is not out
there it's not accurate it's not
reported properly and we need young
people like some of you folks here to do
some of this reporting to dig this stuff
out to write the true history one of the
things that I've talked about in some of
my recent addresses has been the need
for more accurate and more comprehensive
history and I've told this some of you
heard this before
I'm a good friend named Pat Courtin who
used to be the morning anchor on WTOP
our main news station here in Washington
and Pat told me a story that this was in
1994 at the time the 50th anniversary of
d-day he was traveling somewhere in the
Midwest I forget where and had occasion
to watch a television broadcast about
some of the commemorations of d-day in
1994 and he's watching her happen to be
the young lady of the reading off the
telephone
after who referred to world war 11 and
what she indicated to me that maybe
we're not teaching history very well but
also that we're not teaching Latin
although you would think after all these
Super Bowls we would know something
about Roman numerals but apparently not
anyway just a couple of final remarks
and I'll yield the floor to you folks
one is that is written virtually nothing
new Under the Sun although this is not
in this Reeboks everybody knows about
Nixon and Watergate how many people know
about Auto attempt or how many people
know about Jack Kennedy sharing income
tax returns with Ben Bradley or about
the ruther memorandum or the whole
effort to silence conservatives under
Kennedy and then under Johnson I dare
say not many and there a couple reasons
for that one of course is the the
writing of history itself somebody said
that said that history is written by the
victors I differ from them history is
written by people who write history and
by large they are the liberal left
persuasion that's what you've got out
there and we need to correct them the
other reason is that the pushback was
very different under Nixon from what it
was in these other episodes in the case
of the IRS internally as I said there
was very little cooperation within the
IRS with what Nixon was trying to do if
you read about this as always Nixon
wanted to do this he intended to do that
he tried to do this he asked for this he
didn't get it over and over again he was
being you know
rope a dopes by the bureaucrats and IRS
and I've arguably properly so that ain't
the way it is when the president is a
Kennedy or an a-bomb the second reason
is the medium if Barack Obama were a
conservative Republican you can write
that script yourself
there is nothing and we there's a lot we
don't know much remaining to be
discovered and reported when you have an
official of the IRS going through to the
Capitol Hill and taking the Fifth
Amendment that kind of piqued my
curiosity why is she taking to the Fifth
Amendment and another guy took the Fifth
Amendment iris also well good deal I
have another Nixon or Reagan that have
been a very different matter and the
same is true of these other scandals
Benghazi the dad I know this is your
your wheelhouse and what's happening and
that cover-up this is a scandal far
surpassing Watergate four Americans died
there including our ambassador
apparently nothing was done to help them
as far as we know this is all been
stonewalled all been covered up we were
told at the time that the whole uproar
in the Middle East was over a video made
by some poor guy in LA who is in prison
right now in jail
as a result of that we know this was a
lie for sure and yet no accountability
for it Hillary Clinton is before a
Senate committee being asked about this
and says what difference does it make
well you lied that makes some difference
and it certainly made a difference for
Richard Nixon but not for Hillary
Clinton or Barack Obama or the people
that work with them and I one of my
enthusiasms although it's tempered by
some other issues is radio broadcaster
Washington Chris plant who's on WMAL in
the morning and he's a little wobbly on
a couple of issues but otherwise very
entertaining and usually correct and one
of his favorite sayings and has become
one of mine mine also is if it were not
for double standards liberals would have
no standards at all it is so true I'm
going to wrap it up right here my time
is up and I thank you for yours
now okay if you wait for the mic because
your mind hearing issues thank you thank
you mr. Evans you mentioned Benghazi and
the IRS yeah my name is jeiza Watsky I
live here in a Bethesda okay
you mentioned Benghazi and you mentioned
the IRS but you didn't get into the NSA
what do you think about is Snowden a
hero or is he a traitor there's a little
bit of both the NSA thing is a little
more complex not so clear we don't know
enough now we know that what they were
doing was also misrepresented people
went before the Congress and denied that
they were doing this again where's the
accountability for that very very weak
follow-through from the media and from
others so to himself going to Red China
and then Russia is not exactly the
Freedom Trail so I'm okay but I
you could argue over horse he's going to
go but let me talk about the issue
Snowden to me is a sidebar here the
issue itself is what the NSA has been
doing and by the way I was asked to
speak a little louder because they're
recording this NSA yes but
explain the joke but also Hills it was
recording and also this is typical of
the way things are done in the realm of
internal security these days it's as if
you had a murder in Chicago which is not
exactly hypothetical they have them all
the time and I'm in charge of looking at
it and say you know we've got a murder
in Chicago
bring me the Chicago phone book and also
examining every person that phonebook
this is not the way you conduct an
investigation all this drag that
gathering of data the data mining is
self-defeating
and I have some experience in this
because I have to deal with large
quantities of data all in the ER job is
to call out the stuff that isn't
relevant to get to the stuff that is so
you follow leads you know just random
when you look at everything the result
of this is that while they are
collecting data on all of us they're
letting the real culprits slip through
all this is going on these Boston
bombers are up there you know killing
people it's a marathon and by the way
I'm glad at least so far nobody has
suggested that at the finish line of the
Boston Marathon we build a mosque
I mean that that could still NECA still
happening our way of saying no hard
feelings guys you know little mosque but
those guys slipped through while all
this massive data gathering was gone
they paid no attention they had warnings
from Pugh and and elsewhere he god
forbid actors they did nothing about it
this is typical of the way things are
think of airport security well that's
rather unpleasant but they're you know
they're paying down your grandmother and
like some guy in a turban go through and
so but you know Larry the Cable Guy is
you know that is this comedian and yet
he's had his line about some guide in
your air port who had pulled out of line
a woman with a baby and he's you know
going through all that was a big deal
and then Wanda and so forth and the baby
and Larry the Cable Guy says they need
to wake up he said the difference is the
terrorist has the diaper on his head
the but you can't do that see that's
profiling we can do that so we started
randomly patting down everybody and it's
the same thing with the enticing so this
gentleman here after yesterday I had
span just myself I wonder if I could
reach back I really enjoyed your Venona
project book and I wondered if reaching
back how many Soviet spies do you think
were unidentified unpublicized I've
heard numbers like 2 300 I wanted it how
many of based on Vern Oda tapes how many
Soviet spies do you think just you know
went to their graves unrevealed majority
by the way I'm no big of a known expert
that's her bro Mustaine was then but no
no well I wrote didn't write that book
claim I wrote a later book with it but
looking for note I've use it but I'm not
an expert on for those who don't know
Venona is a the code name for a bunch of
decrypted messages from Soviet
intelligence dating to the 1940s period
of world war 11 where we were
intercepting Soviet decrypted messages
and breaking the code and from that
activity a whole bunch of suspects were
identified in the government according
to herb my unfortunately now deceased
co-author and John Haynes and Harvey
Clair who wrote a book about this also
third quality 350 communists or Soviet
agents identified in Venona now Venona
remember was not comprehensive it was
less than three thousand messages out of
many hundreds of thousands so it's not
definitive it's part of a vast database
subject I did write a book about Senator
Joe McCarthy using vanilla which came
out in 2007 and I use vanilla but I also
used the FBI files and what happened was
in that case I got the names of the
McCarthy cases and I spoke about this at
Hillsboro came out and I went to the FBI
under the Freedom of Information
provisions and got FBI files about these
people and if you have their in a very
disorganized state but there are a lot
of them and I got a hundred thousand
pages of these funds in case after case
after case there they are
the McCarthy cases are in those files so
it's not just vanilla it's a lot of
other stuff KTV documents it had to be
many many hundreds but most of them got
away and they're getting away with it
even now because the history books again
don't tell us about it but it's got to
be more than three or four hundred it's
gonna be and if you're economist have an
agent spot your sword spies and I do
have a quibble with them my view is that
the issue is not spying
although certain was a lot of that
policy influence in the new book called
solid secret agents in a diners book
it's called American betrayal
discussions there are about the degree
to which Soviet agents influenced by
policy people Alger Hiss Harry Dexter
white and others many more and that was
the real what-if of Cambridge said that
was the real danger and he's right so
it's not just spies but there were
certainly hundreds of communists in the
government without doubt okay
Paul Hardin live in Alexandria in your
opinion if there had been a Republican
Congress in 1973 and 74 would any of us
in this room know what the word
Watergate meant probably
the reason is it wasn't the Congress
that did it it was the medium the
Congress followed along but Congress did
not really break it until after the
Washington Post when a huge issue of it
and prompted action by the Senate to
form the Senate Watergate committee it
was Sam Ervin and then the House
Judiciary Committee under Peter Rodino
and impeachment hearings but that was
all a consequence not the cause of the
Nixon problem the main problem the Nixon
had was was Jack Anderson journalistic
and Anderson had a source within the
government I'm not sure where and then
Woodward and Bernstein at its source
also and they were leaking these sources
to the journalists and not to the
Congress in their Congress following
along yes sir hi my name is Lex mckusker
so could you go back then to to what
extent was the Watergate prosecution
directed at Nixon because he was a
conservative or for other reasons as you
pointed out his policy record was
suspect let's say and wasn't Nixon's big
crime that he stood by Whittaker
Chambers he let one of perhaps the
biggest truth teller get through the big
lie of the of the period yeah I think
you put your finger on something very
important Nixon made his rep with people
like us in this case and he did break
that case not alone I have a whole
chapter about this in the new book on
stolen secret agent about the effort to
cover up this case by the affirmative
administration when the
clash occurred between chambers and his
brother House committee August 1948
before then and after them but
particularly after the Truman Justice
Department was bet on indicted for
perjury chambers not is and they would
have done it
even after chambers produced the
documents that showed that he was
telling the truth and that this was
lying these are called punkin papers
they still were intent on him in going
after chambers
the reason being the chambers had
previously denied that there had been
espionage now he said there was so there
were technically he also was guilty of
perjury and therefore could have been
indicted but by far the bigger criminal
in the case the felony was yes who
continued to deny lie cover-up for the
rest of his life
and the Justice Department wanted to go
after chambers not his Nixon and Robert
stripling who was the chief counsel to
that committee House committee got the
the actual pumpkin papers this microfilm
from chambers subsequent to that and
refused to turn those documents over to
the Justice Department
without safeguarding them that's what
broke the case the mumping papers so
there's no question that this was this
was something that the left never
forgave Nixon for doing and he was
intensely conscious of this and spent a
lot of time trying to live that down who
ID'd all these other things which didn't
get it much credit from the left when
they saw a chance to do a man they did I
mean that's all that worked
now I'm need to move around here this
gentleman right here in back
thank you so much Tyler O'Neill writer
with the Christian Post also a graduate
of the national journalism Center and
Hillsdale my question is what do you
suggest conservatives especially the Tea
Party do to reverse this trend
especially in the media if the media is
largely responsible for these things and
then also the administration what can
they do I mean I just went to the march
on media event that a bunch of pro-life
groups hosted do you suggest events like
that has anything worked in the past
well now but what we need is a lot of
folks like you and these other young
people to go into journalism we need to
we need more people who are interested
in the truth and not in the agenda of
the left and what you've got
unfortunately is a very strong
representation of the second and not the
first very few journalists out there
doing their job by my observation and
there's some in JC graduate I think you
got there after I left about the in JC I
used to tell our students and I still
teach from the University I say the
answer to spend from the left is not
spent from the right I mean the
temptation is to do that I say even if
I've said to them then and still do when
I teach occasionally now if I have to
support my point of view by suppressing
some of the facts there must be
something wrong with my point of view
why can't I not base my position on the
facts not my conclusion and so many
people going into this business
left or right but mostly left do it the
other way around they start inclusion
and go I didn't try to find stuff that
supports it and that's what they wind up
putting on the air
and the blogosphere or whatever they're
doing we need more honest journalists
practicing German and whatever they
delivered might be in the back al
Millican a.m. media did you have any
personal interaction or recollections of
those that seem to have had gone through
some kind of transformation during
Watergate John Dean was one that seemed
to have be gifted by God with a
photographic memory like Ronald Reagan
was that I'm sure he would have been
discredited if you know the tapes hadn't
surfaced Jeb Magruder had claimed to
have lost his moral compass and then
after going to prison he became an
ordained Presbyterian minister Charles
Colson said he would what walk over his
mother or grandmother for Richard Nixon
but then you know he became a born-again
Christian and created one of the great
Christian ministries a prison fellowship
I'm wondering what do you remember about
those people in particular Colson
I've had to meet Colson after it was all
over I do nothing about him at the time
somebody made a joke about Colson he
wrote that he wrote a piece for The
Reader's Digest called how I walked over
my grandmother and found God that's kind
of what you just said but I don't I
didn't really know any of them at all I
can I can show you this that the the
Nixon atmosphere was not something I
found congenial I did not hang out with
those people I was a conservative then
as I am today and I did not like a lot
of what they were doing so I didn't
really spend a lot of time with them and
I also most of the demos in Indiana I
was right
so I really did not get to know them
personally at all okay couple more right
here we have time for just one more
question here one more this young man
here yes sir
I'm Brian and I'm a student here in
Washington to what extent would you see
a parallel between the iran-contra
scandal under Ronald Reagan and both
Watergate and what's happening now none
I covered iran-contra very carefully at
the time there was nothing illegal about
iran-contra get a little bit complicated
but I wrote about it in great detail
iran-contra arose because of something
called me Boland amendment every Bolla
was the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee in that era
Democrat and a member was passed to
prevent the use of appropriate of tax
money this is all spelled out in the
records to support the Contras simply
part of the left-wing effort to help the
Sandinistas who were communists in
Nicaragua
the reason iran-contra developed the way
it did was because Ollie north who's in
the White House might know that I know
him there but I'm not him since was also
involved in a deal with the Iranians
about hostages and so forth and the
details are not germane here as a result
of this certain funds were made
available to the National Security
Council we're all in works that were not
appropriated tax money and Ollie crossed
the wires he said why don't we use this
money to help the conference this was
not forbidden by the bowl amendment the
amendment says nothing about them he
says appropriated under this law tax
money this was not tax money so rank
tatra was to me a totally bogus
Kendyl it was complicated
I for it first reacted but rather a few
times I got a call from President Reagan
in that Europe and my office is right
down the street here on Second Street
which caused great hullabaloo and my
office says it Reagan is calling me I
had given a quote to United Press saying
we should not trade money or arms for
hostages I gotta say there's a story
that Allah chose their great story has
nothing to do with your question but but
it's a great story kind of theater
Jacobsen who's one of the hostages in
Lebanon that all had got released and I
met him at an event with Olli and
whenever it was after that early 90s I
guess Theodore Jacobson had been tied up
gagged and driven around Beirut
in the trunk of several cars and kept
there like that for several days and I
was on a platform with him and he said I
must say that and there were some people
there from GM if it's meeting quest for
true they said if you're going to be
locked up with the trunk of a car I
would recommend the Mercedes actually
said
a much more comfortable trunk that's it
yeah actually said this is that a while
that is really good to come out of that
kind of experience with that line
anyway that's what lolly was doing he
was getting these people out from under
that mess in Lebanon and the money arose
complicated ways from those transactions
here the arms tow missiles being sold to
Iran and so forth one of the ironies
about that was that Holly and others
involved in doing that were trashed
because they were helping at that time
Iran against Iraq
the iran-iraq war was going on at that
time and the MEP ins that were
transmitted to Iran from Israel by
remembering this correctly on telegram
25 years were defensive tow missiles
purely defensive weapons but this was
considered an outrage and you know why
because we were betraying our great ally
Saddam Hussein that was the line in 86
how could you do this to poor Saddam
Hussein and give me a break and so Chris
we found out later that Saddam Hussein
was not that great
it was okay but even nothing time is up
thank you all